[Musique]
bonsoir
est ce que vous êtes déjà demandé par
quoi est ce que nous allons bien pouvoir
remplacer le pétrole
c'est une question fondamentale et c'est
une question fondamentale parce que nous
sommes vous le savez nous le savons dans
une transition fondamentale et cette
transition l'appel aujourd'hui la
transition énergétique
cette transition qui a connu connu un
coup d'accélérateur absolument fabuleux
en 2015 notamment avec cette coque 21 et
qui a donné lieu aux accords de paris de
décembre 2015
l'idée centrale principale de cette
transition énergétique c'est que le
pétrole les énergies fossiles sont un
problème pour l'environnement
il faut décarbonés nos économies il faut
décarbonés nos énergies
il faut se sevrer parlera de cette
dépendance au pétrole de façon à ce que
et bien il y ait moins de gaz à effet de
serre et ceux ci c'est la condition de
la lutte contre le réchauffement
climatique
et puis merde qu'est ce qu'on en fait
qu'est ce qu'on met à la place de ces
technologies qui utilisent le pétrole on
met ce que vous connaissez
on met des technologies vertes les
technologies vertes ce sont des panneaux
solaires des éoliennes
les voitures électriques ce sont aussi
des technologies numériques
c'est à dire des téléphones portables
des tablettes des ordinateurs puisqu'il
faut du numérique pour ensuite permettre
de rendre ces technologies vertes plus
efficiente
c'est ce qu'on appelle l'efficacité
énergétique simplement ces technologies
là elles ont elles aussi besoin de
matières premières pas de pétrole mais
d'autres matières premières et des
matières premières tellement importante
tellement essentiel que les industriels
qui les utilisent les scientifiques nos
si les chefs d'états les appels déjà
pour certaines
the next wave le prochain pétrole de
quoi parle-t-on
personne ne sait
pourtant nos aïeux au 19ème siècle savez
très bien l'importance du charbon au 20e
siècle
on savait très bien la nécessité du
pétrole pour nos mix énergétique nous
21e siècle nous ne savons pas forcément
que un monde plus vert dépend de ce
nouveau pétrole des nouveaux équilibres
énergétiques dépendent de ce nouve
pétrole qu'on appelle les métaux rares
dans la nature vous avez des métaux
abondant tout le monde connaît les
métaux les grands métaux abondants on
parle du fer on parle du zinc on parle
du cuivre on parle de l'aluminium
simplement y a pas que ça dans l'écorcé
terrestre dans les gisements
naturellement mélangé à ces métaux
abondants on trouve également des petits
métaux on les appelle rare parce que
leur proportion dans la corse terrestre
est infiniment moindres que les grands
métaux quelquefois c'est des milliers de
fois moindre mais on sait les extraire
et on sait les séparait des grands
métaux et depuis une quarantaine
d'années on sait les utiliser pour leurs
fabuleuses propriétés électromagnétiques
électronique catalytique optique etc et
il rentre dans toutes les technologies
vertes vous avez besoin de ces métaux
pour fabriquer des éoliennes la plupart
des éoliennes mais également pour
fabriquer des panneaux solaires pour
fabriquer des voitures électriques et
pour fabriquer le léviathan numérique
tout ce monde numérique qui permet de
rendre ces technologies vertes plus
efficiente
alors ces métaux il y en a une trentaine
et si je commence à vous en citer
quelques-uns ont fait un peu de poésie
ensemble on parle de samarium gadolinium
lutétium de cobalt de néodyme de
tungstène de tantale herlin que j'aime
bien c'est le pro médium j'aime bien ce
mot là on utilise très peu finalement sa
télé non mais j'aime bien le prométhéen
parce qu'il a été baptisé quand il a été
découvert dans les années 1940 par un
chimiste par la femme d'un chemise qui
avait dit mais en fait avec cet élément
là c'est comme si on avait le feu aux
dieux comme prométhée vous allez le
titan qui s'est introduit dans l'olympe
et qui avait volé faits odieux pour le
rendre aux hommes et donc on a appelé ce
cet élément le premier homme parce que
finalement à vous et moi on ne sait pas
mais il nous a donné les pouvoirs
prométhéen grâce à lui toutes les
technologies vertes fonctionne grâce à
lui et à tous ses autres métaux cette
trentaine de métaux rares toutes les
technologies numériques fonctionne à
l'instant où je vous parle vous et moi
avant tout sur nous des métaux rares
vous en avez dans votre téléphone vous
en avez dans vos écouteurs j'en ai un
dans mon écouteurs vous rentrerez
peut-être dans une voiture électrique
qui concerne les métaux rares nous ne
pourrions pas passé une seule journée
sur terre à vivre même après une seule
heure sans utiliser d'une façon ou d'une
autre ces métaux rares simplement je
suis un journaliste et je me suis dit
mais essaie mais tout est ce qu'on va
aller les chercher ces matières
premières qui justement vous remplacer
le pétrole
à quel coût pour les hommes et pour
l'environnement allons-nous les extraits
en sécuriser les approvisionnements et
pendant plusieurs années j'ai fait le
tour de la planète plusieurs fois dans
une douzaine de pays pour essayer de
remonter le fil de ces nouvelles
matières premières qui sont en train de
remplacer pétrole à la faveur de la
transition énergétique est ce que j'ai
découvert ma pour ne rien vous cacher
déniaisé par rapport à la transition
énergétique parce que dans mon esprit la
transition énergétique c'était une
transition plus verte plus sobre plus
responsable et puis quand on la regarde
sous l'angle de ses petits métaux rares
en réalité on voit une autre phase
peut-être plus sombre de cette
transition verte
nous sommes en 2016 et je me trouve en
chine et plus précisément dans la
province du jiangxi
c'est une province qui se trouve au sud
de la chine pas très loin de hong kong
d'abord c'est un cetain une province qui
est magnifique c'est la chine qu'on
aimerait voir plus souvent la chine
verte avec des collines et des pains de
sucre à perte de vue une nature
généreuse la province de jiangxi c'est
pas que ça c'est aussi l'une des
principales zones d'extraction de
certains métaux rares puis après plus
précisément des métaux rares qu'on
appelle les terres rares les terreur est
une sous catégorie de métaux rares et
donc cette province de jalousie c'est là
l'une des premières zones d'exploitation
de cette terreur de la planète et il
faut s'enfoncer assez loin dans la dans
la dans cette région qui était un petit
peu les sentiers battus pour aller voir
comment se passe l'extraction de ces
métaux déjà choc visuel vous avez des
collines qui sont coupées en deux dans
le sens de la verticale pour aller
extraire les métaux on se retrouve nez à
nez avec des mafias qui font du marché
noir et puis surtout on comprend aussi
on commence à comprendre les impacts
écologiques de l'extraction de ces
métaux puisqu'il faut à les extraire et
qui se trouve dans les proportions
infimes
imaginez les efforts qu'il faut pour
l'extraire
un kilo de ces métaux il faut retourner
des centaines des milliers des dizaines
de milliers de tonnes de callas il va
falloir ensuite séparé ces métaux des
métaux a bondi à voir les purifie
utiliser des produits chimiques
nous sommes en chine ça se passe pas
forcément aussi bien qu'on ne le
voudrait
sur le plan de l'environnement ces eaux
sont ensuite rejetés dans les rivières
plus rien ne pousse les personnes qui
travaillent dans ce secteur vous disent
mais c'est un poison ces métaux rares en
réalité ce à un coût environnemental
extrêmement élevé à la même époque
quelques années plus tôt je vous trouvez
dans une zone zone une autre zone
d'extraction de métaux rares de terres
rares plus précisément en chine sans
mongolie intérieure c'est dans le nord
de la chine 700 km au nord ouest de
pékin
et là c'est la plus grande zone
d'extraction et là c'est carrément
l'enfer de dante
ce sont des lacs toxiques dans laquelle
on rejette tous les effluents chargés de
produits chimiques et de et de et de
métaux lourds
ces effluents qui ont servi pour le
raffinage de ces métaux on se retrouve à
parler avec des avec des avec des avec
des gens qui travaillent dans cette
industrie mais aussi les riverains qui
habitent dans des villages baptisé
village du cancer parce que on meurt
dans ces villages d'un taux anormalement
élevé de cancer et le lien avec
l'industrie
selon ces villageois est évident ils
mangent boivent respirent les effluents
toxiques des mines et de métaux rares
est d aider d une et des rejets de
métaux lourds qui ont servi au raffinage
des métaux rares une experte chinoise me
dit la chine a sacrifié son
environnement pour fournir le reste du
monde
avec ces métaux rares et là je me prends
une claque
parce que je me dis mais attendez je
comprends pas et je m'identifie
immédiatement deux paradoxes que je
voudrais partager avec vous le premier
paradoxe c'est que les énergies vertes
vite propres se fonde sur l'exploitation
de métaux qui ne sont pas propres qui
sont sales les énergies renouvelables ne
peuvent exister sans l'extraction de
matières premières qui elles ne sont pas
renouvelables
est ce que je vous dis en chine ça vaut
pour un tas de pays où on extrait tous
ces métaux rares on peut parler du
cobalt au congo
on peut parler de métaux divers et
variés au kazakhstan j'étais également
en amérique latine il est extrêmement
difficile en amérique latine d'ouvrir
une mine aujourd'hui parce que les
populations riveraines sont vent debout
contre les projets d'extraction minière
tellement c'est sale et tellement c'est
problématique pour l'environnement et je
me dis mais comment ça se fait que je
n'ai pas réalisé cela plutôt comment ça
se fait que je découvre cette histoire
ses dessous des technologies vertes si
tard alors que pourtant cette industrie
existe depuis des décennies à la même
époque je me trouve aux états unis et je
me trouve plus précisément dans la
région de las vegas la frontière entre
la californie le nevada et à cette
époque là bas se trouvaient une mine
dans les années 90 cette époque se
trouver une mine de mountain pass
c'était le nom de la mine et cette mine
était la première mine d'extraction de
terres rares donc une classe de métaux
rares de la planète
le problème c'est que dans les années 90
ça commençait à problème posé de sérieux
problèmes environnementaux et ça posait
tellement de problématiques
environnementales
ça faisait enfin la minière la compagnie
minière qui s'appelait molly corps se
retrouver aux prises avec des tas de
difficulté et avec aussi
l'administration américaine qui
compliquait les choses parce que les
réglementations environnementales était
strict que finalement elle s'est rendue
compte sept compagnies minières qu'elle
ne pouvait plus continuer à extraire ces
terres rares health a dit puisque c'est
ça je ferme la mine toujours les années
90 il y avait un autre pays qui est un
leader de ces métaux rares c'était la
france à la rochelle
il y avait une usine qui s'appelait
rhône poulenc rhône poulenc n'était pas
seulement le sponsor de l'émission
ushuaïa que présenté nicolas hulot chez
pas si vous rappeler c'était aussi un
chimiste qui purifiait 50% des terres
rares de la planète
et rhône poulenc se trouve à cette
époque dans les mêmes problématiques que
celles de molycorp non pas pour
l'extraction mais pour le raffinage
problématique des queues de pollution
quand on extrait les terres rares et qu
on les sépare en fait du thorium et de
l'uranium auquel sont associés ça génère
de la radioactivité
les rochelais ne supportait pas à cette
situation ça crée des troubles sociaux
les coûts de l'extraction de ces métaux
de la purification ces métaux commencé à
exploser n'était plus rentable rhône
poulenc se dit on délocalise nos
activités en chine donc au même moment
vous avez une minière une compagnie
minière est une compagnie d'extraction
et de raffinage pardon de ces métaux
rares qui en fait deux concerts mais
sans se concerter décide soit fermées
soit délocaliser leur activité et à ce
moment là qui récupère le bébé
eh bien ce sont les chinois parce que
dans ces années là les chinois vous
disent 'vous savez mao ça c'est pas
hyper bien passé pour nous la révolution
agricole
sap a exactement eu le succès escompté
on mise tout sur l'industrie et on a
plein de gisements de terres rares et de
métaux rares en général on peut vous
fournir des terres rares pas cher
abondante
on va sacrifier notre environnement mais
c'est pas grave nous ce qui nous importe
c'est le développement économique et
nous on s'est débarrassé l'état rare
donc en fait ce faisant on n'a pas
seulement délocaliser nos emplois on n'a
pas seulement délocaliser nos usines
nous avons délocalisé la pollution nous
avons délocalisé la pollution associée à
ces matières premières ce nouveau
pétrole nécessaire aux technologies
vertes
nous avons laissé des pays salir pour
extraire et purifier ces métaux
de sorte que nous puissions les racheté
pure propre les mettre dans les
technologies vertes et nous glorifier de
notre conversion écolo en fait pour le
dire autrement le monde s'est séparé de
façon grosso modo entre ceux qui font du
sale ceux qui sont sales et ceux qui
font semblant d'être propre
alors est-ce que je suis audible avec
tout ça finalement
moi je me demande si chaud dip dans la
mesure où notre consommation
électroniques notre consommation de
technologies vertes explose elle est
exponentielle nous sommes dans un monde
où tout le monde toujours plus
électronique tombe toujours plus
d'énergie verte
les chinois veulent vivre comme des
français ils veulent aller se faire
photographier devant la tour eiffel
ils veulent vivre comme des européens
comme des occidentaux il ya une
convergence des modes de vie entre les
pays développés et les pays en mode en
voie de développement qui fait qu' il va
y avoir une explosion de la demande de
consommation de ces métaux rares rapport
qui a été publié en 2013 10 ème et 17
minutes 2035 il va nous falloir deux
fois plus de terres rares quatre fois
plus de tantale neuf fois plus de
scandium 24 fois plus de cobalt 180 fois
plus de lithium
etc etc etc c'est exponentiel un expert
français du cnrs a fini par se dire mais
est-ce qu'on peut calculer un peu les
besoins globaux en métaux qui sont
nécessaires compte tenu de nouveaux
modes de vie il a fait un calcul qui m'a
laissé complètement pantois il a
remarqué que compte tenu de notre
consommation de toutes sortes de
technologies pas seulement les verts
télé numérique mais contenue nos besoins
futurs pour les 30 prochaines années
et bien dans les trente prochaines
années l'humanité va consommer davantage
de métaux que tous les métaux qu'elle
n'a jamais extrait depuis le début de
l'humanité depuis soixante-dix mille ans
c'est à dire que les générations la
génération des 25 30 prochaines années
va consommer davantage que les 2500
générations qui les ont précédés
il va falloir aller chercher toujours
plus de métaux donc on commence à se
dire on va aller ouvrir des mines un peu
partout et puis les océans regorge de
métaux et puis l'espace regorge de
métaux les américains commencent à s'y
intéresser
nous nous sommes en train d'étendre le
domaine de la mine pour pouvoir nous
fournir en métaux abondant mais aussi en
métaux rares pour nos nouveaux besoins
énergétique et numérique et je souligne
encore une fois un paradoxe transition
énergétique
tout ça au nom de la sobriété ce qui
pose à un an des problématiques de
pénurie
commence déjà dressé des listes de
pénurie en disant mais oui mais à ce
rythme d'exploitation là telle ou telle
ou telle métal
on en aura plus apte à l'horizon nous
sommes à la veille d'une renaissance
nous sommes en plein dans une nouvelle
renaissance technologique
c'est un mot qui enthousiasme tout le
monde et est même moi je voudrais y
croire mais simplement que se passe-t-il
si vous êtes dans une renaissance et
qu'il n'y a pas assez de matière
première pour cette renaissance que se
serait-il passé en 492,6 christophe
colomb faute de bois disponible n'avait
pas trouvé ces deux bateaux amarrés
import andalou alors que faire eh bien
d'abord je pense qu'il faut méditer
cette phrase d'einstein and stay nous a
donné une phrase magnifique il a dit on
ne règle pas un problème avec les modes
de penser qu'ils ont engendrez or nous
sommes en train d'essayer de régler un
problème avec les mêmes modes de penser
qu'ils ont engendrez nous pensons cette
transition de façon purement
technologique mais nous ne pensons pas
de façon je dirais plus culturelle plus
personnel nous avons une problématique
c'est que nous voulons faire des sauts
technologiques sanso de conscience nous
pouvons faire des progrès techniques
sans nécessairement penser à des progrès
humain et là une façon d'appliquer cette
maxime
c'est peut-être de regarder concrètement
ce qu'on peut faire pour rationaliser la
matière rationaliser la matière par
exemple eh bien c'est arrêter de
recycler tous les métaux rares on
recycle moins de 1% de métaux rares
aujourd'hui puisque en fait c'est trop
cher de les recycler on sait ferme on ne
veut pas faire on pourrait substituer
certains métaux par d'autres moins
énergivores il faudrait échos concevoir
toutes les technologies de façon à
pouvoir les recycler plus facilement
après il faudrait lutter contre
l'obsolescence programmée des produits
qui est un scandale qui nous pousse à
consommer davantage
a lille il ya une entreprise qui
s'appelle vitamine t cette entreprise
génère un chiffre d'affaires de 60
millions d'euros emploie 3500 salariés
et recycle 40 mille tonnes de déchets
électroniques
une autre entreprise envie nord récupère
et remet sur le marché neuf mille
produits électroménagers parents sont
des exemples très concrets de progrès
qui peuvent être faits sont
nécessairement
devoir remettre en cause
fondamentalement nos modèles de
croissance mais il faut rationaliser la
matière et gardez aussi à l'esprit cette
belle phrase des énergéticiens qu'ils
disent
la meilleure énergie finalement c'est
celle que nous ne consommons pas et pour
terminer je vous dirais simplement que
j'en parlais justement avec un avec un
expert et cet expert et il nous l'a il
me laissait finalement il me proposait
cette phrase et cette maxime plein de
bon sens et de et d'espoir aussi une
disait vous avez finalement guillaume on
n'a pas de problème de matières rares
nous n'avons que les problèmes de
matière grise
je vous remercie